nick swisher i hope you bring some
energy energy today buddy how you doing
oh bro bring it back for you every day
man you know that
[Laughter]
great great to hear from you man uh i
always enjoy
talking about all things baseball and
especially enjoy
having these conversations with you and
your yankees are struggling
uh as you know i grew up in a red sox
household so with the yankees having the
season they're having right now
what's the biggest problem out in the
bronx and do you think the series
against
my dad's socks will get him back on
track
and by the way it was kind of cool to
see a totally different lineup out there
feel like that lineup brought a little
more energy kind of brought a little
different vibe
uh than you know than what it had been
but listen man this is the second half
of the season this is where
the yankees historically have absolutely
thrived
and listen man it's not how you start
it's how you finish we've all heard that
and i think right now if you're looking
at the lineup moving forward
i think for myself obviously being able
to get guys like aaron judge back
you know george shella kyle higashioka
all those guys
as well as jonathan lewis got coming out
of the bullpen you know i think if
you're looking at it man luis severino
is right around the corner
right so being able to get somebody like
him back even though
i think he'll be at his best probably
next season
it even to be able to bring a
right-handed power arm like that i
definitely think gives this team a jolt
listen definitely kind of put themselves
behind the eight ball a little bit the
boston red sox have had
a tremendous season as hard as that is
for me to say
it's been a lot of fun to watch the
successes those guys have had
and also to the rise of a team like the
tampa
or like the toronto blue jays vladimir
guerrero jr i mean we're talking about
the
front runner other than ohtani uh for
being the mvp
as well as the tampa bay rays man so
everyone knows how good they are
i think the alex is back man it's
awesome to see four
amazing teams that can compete for that
first place spot man it's gonna be a lot
of fun to see what happens down the
stretch
but coming from my pinstripe blood it's
coming baby
the boys are coming back i think they've
got a new energetic way about going
about their business this second half
and i'm really excited to see what's
going to happen nick i really miss the
days of heading out to the bronx to sit
out there in the bleachers and scream go
blue
and different michigan things at you
being that you're an ohio guy
i used to love doing that when you
played right feel for for the yankees
but
now the fans are interacting with the
players in a much different way
you've had some encounters of course
with the bleacher creatures over the
years
on 161st street in the bronx but when
you saw what happened to verdugo the
other night
what were your thoughts and did it make
you think about any kind of interactions
that you had with fans
throughout your career yeah no place
right no place in sports any you know
listen you try and create a a safe place
uh for athletes um and you know
understanding going to a game
you know that sort of stuff can't be
happening i i don't think whoever that
individual was
is going to be watching any baseball
games anywhere other than his living
room i think for a while
uh according to you know being banned
from all 30 ballparks
there's there's no place for that sports
man i i thought that's just a bad look
uh listen man i mean i know the yankee
uh red sox rivalry
is strong but you know listen you know
uh
no place for that in sports man i've
even thinking myself i've never you know
never had something like that thrown at
me never a ball
but quarters batteries things like that
but i mean come on man we're talking you
know mid-2000s right there i mean things
have changed a little bit
in that time but for me you know i i
think you know spectators need to
understand these athletes are going out
there given everything they have
trying to create a safe place for them
um would be something that you would
want to do
so yeah no place for that in the game
but you know listen some other things
happen
um but i don't want you know one
individual
um you know one apple spoiling the whole
bunch you know what i mean
nick swisher joins the show fox sports
mlb analyst lives by the code if
you don't what's the code nick don't bro
me unless you know me that's those are
the words to live by
don't promise you know me baby don't bro
me unless you know me nick swisher joins
the show
ben lyons in for rich on the rich eisen
show walk us through your mindfulness
routine uh nick are you meditating these
days what are you doing to kind of bring
bring it inward
are you working on a wim hof breath
routine well talk to me through your
self-care
yeah right bro uh right now man i'm a
stay-at-home dad baby
you know right now you know we just got
back here to tampa
joe finished doing uh second season of
sweet magnolias
which i could not be more proud of her
man it's been an absolute awesome season
and for myself man just kind of getting
back into the flow of things
uh for myself you know being you know a
special advisor with the yanks
you know i get the opportunity and the
pleasure uh to go and watch the next
crop of young
athletes right the next crop of young
stars
uh that are coming through so for myself
i was able to go down uh to the facility
today watch some young kids play a
little ball
especially all the new draft kids that's
the that's the best part
is meeting these kids seeing how
wide-eyed they are
and for myself man just letting them
know hey welcome to the family
uh it's time to get to work can you
imagine you're a young player
to have all those things for me bro i'm
digging it can you imagine you're a
young player
you're living out your dream to play
major league baseball you get called up
by the new york yankees
the most historic and prestigious team
you're gonna put on the pinstripes
and your first day you're like your
first day of school and you meet
professor swish
and this guy shakes your hand
you know what you already did you
already heard from me on instagram so
we've already communicated
i'm telling you man i feel like that's
such a a great way
uh to keep in touch with a lot of my
players
uh is directly through instagram man
it's been a a great outlet for me it's
been a great communication
uh tool uh but bro for me you know me
man i'm loving on you man i i want the
best for you
you know i want to bring energy to the
ballpark i want to bring excitement and
i want you to know
how blessed and fortunate that you are
to be able to be putting on the
pinstripes i think there's something to
be said for that man
the culture you create uh is is exactly
what you're going to get out of it
and for myself man you know bleeding
pinstripes bro it's it's very easy for
me
uh to push that yankee way because in my
mind
uh you know it's the best way nick
swisher joins the show
friend of the show hanging out with ben
lyons here filling in for rich on the
rich eisen show
and you talked about the draft and
representing the yankees a tremendous
honor for you obviously and like you
said a great way to get connected with
the next generation of players
i saw the anaheim angels draft board
nick
20 picks 20 pictures that was crazy
didn't take one position player to me
that tells me what their future plans
are with ohtani
if they want to sign him long term i
would imagine that at some point they're
going to have to get him
off the mound and put him in the
outfield or having dh or do something
else when you're sitting back watching
ohtani a
are you thinking about what it would be
like to face him as a hitter
and b what do you think about the angel
strategy of taking pictures and is it
connected to
ohtani's future in the sport uh well i
tell you what i am thinking i'm thinking
what it would like to be
here bro i mean come on this guy is like
a monster sensation he's six foot six
listen bro you heard the story about the
150 stacks he got
for participating in the derby and he
gave it all away
bro come on man like people don't just
do that
i think that's bigger than anything he's
ever done so far in the game
was just his overall will to give back
to the people that have made the
experience
great for him like that's unbelievable
to me i'm thinking to myself he just
gave a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars away
oh my i mean bro come on listen he hits
balls out
into outer space he throws a hundred he
hits it a hundred
he is so huge for the game and for young
athletes man because
it's that dual threat right i mean
that's what i did when i was coming up i
would pitch
i play first i play center i play all
over the place it's not about being
specialized it's being able to be that
all-around athlete and to be able to
have somebody as
athletic as ohtani in my mind probably
the most athletic guy on the field at
all times other than maybe you know
us chapman who's probably right up there
with him i mean
these guys are to bring these athletes
into our game and it's huge
it's huge for this young generation to
watch what's happening
because they want to be otani we need
those role models we need those stars in
our game
especially if we want to grow it so to
have ohtani part of mlb
and to almost be in a sense right now
the big story the face of mlb
brother i mean everything he's doing on
and off the field is spot on i'm a huge
fan
and i think everybody else should take
notes because this guy's doing it the
right way
you mentioned the idea of playing you
know multiple positions for multiple
sports and just showcasing your natural
athleticism
as opposed to being a specialist but
coming out here and pitching
and batting it's what the best kid on
the team always did in little league
oh with kelly leake baby come on
and now he's continuing to do it in the
show it's remarkable i know you're a
huge fan of all sports
uh and with the olympics coming up you
seem to be the kind of guy who maybe
thought about pursuing
you know one of these fringe sports one
of these olympic sports how do you think
you would have fared nick
in rock climbing or team handball or
could you put on the spandex and do
cycling
hey brother hey what if that was my path
baby whatever you need me to do
right like listen handball i think i
would have been pretty good
got pretty good hand-eye skills right i
mean what were the other some some of
the other ones you were talking about
ping pong has a ping pong game who is
the best ping pong player on the 09
yankees
oh man ping pong would have been epic
you know baseball players got great hand
eye we could be up there in that
cycling definitely work on my cardio not
my thing i'm more of an anaerobic guy
um but i'm telling you man i'm a monster
olympic guy i love watching these
because it's
listen it's four years of discipline and
maybe
more to get to this moment and you get
one opportunity
one chance all that training for one
opportunity man
it's unbelievable the emotions are
running high
i'm bro i'm stoked i love that i just
the overall
just um uh the the love that people have
for their countries it comes out man i
dig all that stuff man so
i can't wait for the olympics to get
going on for all the american athletes
as well as all the athletes man i can't
wait to watch man
put on a great show for us one sport
swisher would have crushed that
sumo sumo swisher oh no
no rock climbing bro i got pretty good
grip strength so
maybe but i don't know i don't know man
i know i know you'll be watching i know
you're fired up to
to watch all the olympics coverage
obviously just as a fan of all sports
and i'm some tells me
you're dialed in for game six tonight
bucks and sons does chris paul have
something left in the tank shock the
world or is it tonight the coronation of
giannis
wow bro giannis is fantastic right
i mean everything that we've seen even
booker's been amazing cp3
i mean come on it's been a great story
for both squads
uh but at the end of the day man listen
bro it's hard to stop giannis he's
putting up absolutely
you know nintendo type numbers so i
think right now man it's
i mean listen it it's hard not to go
with your honest as far as hard not to
go with the bucks right now
um and for him the crown you know be
crowned the champion bro i mean
bigger faster stronger i mean the guy's
absolutely unbelievable on the court a
lot of fun to watch you know nick we
were thinking about what he must be like
in the moments before the game he's so
intense
focused locked in take us into the
locker room of the 2009 world series
what's your demeanor like before
the final game focused right
i mean like at this moment you don't
have to tell anybody what to do you know
what's on the line
uh and if you can't feel that in your
bones baby you might be in the wrong
business
i think right now from where those guys
are the nerves are going crazy
uh obviously you want to finish the job
right you want to finish the story
finish the race
uh so for those guys right now man to be
able to have the ability to lock that
thing up tonight
go for it because anything can happen in
the game seven you know that
i feel like nick before a game would
have been lmfao
party rock but it sounds like he was
really locked in and focused
i feel like he would have been jacked up
i mean he's he i'm like that all the
time
right like at the end of the day you
don't want to do something you don't
want to be somebody you're not right
like be authentic be you
right at this moment everybody knows
their routines everyone knows what they
need to do right
everybody knows who's counting on who so
in that locker room right now man
nothing but love
excitement uh and a lot of nerves for
sure well said nick swisher joins the
show
mlb analyst for fox and now returning
down to tampa
you seeing tampa down there you seeing
tampa tam down at the tam tampa where
are you home bro what what do you mean
you mean down here
yeah you seeing tv 12 down there you
guys running you run into each other
tampa bay down there no man we've been
yeah we've been we've been having
celebrations down here like seems like
every other season right now bro you
know i mean i feel like everybody's
getting together down here in temple it
feels like it's like manhattan beach
east where all the athletes are here in
southern
california hanging around mb now you got
the lightning you got
tom brady you got swish doing it big
down at like a don
shula steakhouse in tampa what's the
vibe
bro the fact that you just said swish
and tom brady in the same sentence bro
i'm taking it bro i'm taking it bro
uh nick swisher joins the show and if
you're looking at the back half of the
season here swish
as we wrap things up you know brockman's
a die-hard socks fan
you know my dad's red sox fan i know
there's a lot of red over there for sure
i know it
you know i'm getting emails every time
verdugo does anything
what are the red sox chances for
continuing the the exciting first half
into the second half you think they got
a real shot to win this thing
huge huge huge chance and remember chris
sales right around the corner
right everybody almost forgot about him
guess what former cy young he's coming
back too
and he's going to be healthy so i i
think listen you know
if you're coming from a yankee fan for
myself listen like you know we got a lot
of games left with the rays
with the red sox we control our own
destiny but
those teams aren't laying over and i
think something else
i think the power shifted in the east in
a sense to where you know those teams
the red sox the rays
the you know toronto blue jays they're
not scared of the bronx bombers
they're not scared of the new york
yankees they go toe to toe with them
so i think at the end of the day listen
you know a lot of work to do in new york
but a lot of talent is in that locker
room man they can go on a run just like
anyone else can
but right now if you're the boston red
sox listen you put yourself in a great
position right now
and you've got some people coming back
uh you know i mean
literally i mean everything they've done
from their three four five
batters i mean the best in the big
leagues man that's the bogart's devers
and uh jd martinez come on you know i'm
rooting for them nick so my mother has a
great summer because it just improves
everything in the lion's family
household when the socks are doing well
[Laughter]
man you know i mean listen they've had a
tremendous season thus far man
and they put themselves in the driver's
seat and listen if you're talking about
you know making a playoff run listen man
you know you you feel like they have the
arms in that rotation to do it
uh offensively nobody's been better uh
right now you know you gotta feel like
boston's in the driver's seat right now
in the ale
send my love to joe and the family we
appreciate you checking in man don't bro
me unless you know me nick swisher the
greatest
next time we'll have some time for your
your mantras and your meditation routine
okay buddy
i'm big on affirmations baby put it out
in the universe y'all if you want it to
come true you know it
nick swisher good brother thanks so much
man
talk to y'all later city needed a hero
gotham needed a hero we put up the bat
signal and swisher saved the day
yeah hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here